senator ted cruz gave yale students a
reality check over the attempts to
silence conservatives at their school
and campuses all across america
and i gotta tell you when you come out
of school
most places you work are not safe spaces
most bosses are not going to be overly
worried
about injuring your fragile feelings
and so
i think the point of education is to
prepare you for life and that means
encountering things that make you
uncomfortable that make you doubt that
make you question
that's really what an education is all
about senator cruz along with many
others also signing an open letter
demanding that yale punish the
disruptors or the protesters at last
month's free speech event author and
reuben report host dave rubin joins us
now to react dave what about the the
senator going back uh to the eye of the
storm with that school with thought
which was remarkably unpopular with the
student body
well good for ted cruz and of course ted
cruz is completely right here look you
have a right to protest it's the most
american right there is you can voice
your opinion and you can do it
peacefully and properly and that's what
the free exchange of ideas is all about
what you can't do is use your free
speech to shout down somebody else you
can't lock doors you can't pull fire
alarms the litany of other things that
we've seen students do over the last you
know five to ten years or so and it's
sort of like at this point enough is
enough we have let the inmates run the
asylum at virtually every college in
america and until the administrators the
professors the donors until they all
decide
this can't happen anymore it's going to
continue to happen i suspect at this
point the institutions are probably too
infected and we just need to build new
things because it doesn't seem no matter
how many times you guys talk about it
and not change about it or ben shapiro
talks about it they just keep marching
so maybe we just actually need new
things well that's a great point but the
irony of that event we were looking at
where the the speakers were shouted down
is it was a free speech event
and they didn't want to hear one side of
it and i think it was about a week after
that then a federal judge
suggested on appeals court suggested he
sent an email out to other judges and he
said i don't think we should hire clerks
from yale law school because i don't
know that they can be fair given the
fact that they won't even listen to both
sides of a story
well brian first off it's 2022 irony is
long since dead so there's nothing we
can do on the irony factor uh but yes i
mean this is the problem because it's
not just that we're allowing these kids
to shout down speakers who are invited
by the school i mean we're in ted cruz's
case we're talking about a sitting
senator right it's not just that it's
that then the education
that these kids get the very things they
learn the things that law students
should learn related to the exchange of
free speech and protest and peaceful
protest they're learning all the wrong
things then they get out into into the
real world and as ted cruz said you get
out to the real you have a real job you
better be ready for occasionally someone
might say something upsetting to you and
it doesn't get it doesn't mean you get
to burn down the office you're in or
take down the company with you which
seemingly is happening all over the
country dave i'm glad you said burn down
because your book is called don't burn
this country surviving and thriving in
our woke dystopia and it's on sale today
it reminds me of what ronald reagan said
in his inaugural address in 1967 and
this is a quote from it freedom is a
fragile thing and it's never more than
one generation away from extinction it
is not ours by way of inheritance it
must be fought for and defended
constantly by each generation for it
comes only once to a people tell us
about your book
man does that quote ring true now or
what in essence that very much is what
the book is about you know we can all
mock the woke kids and make fun of them
for the gender pronouns and that
suddenly two plus two is five and that
being non-racist is suddenly racist and
the rest of the stuff but you have to
give the devil his due that really is
what this book is about they have
marched through our cultural
institutions our educational
institutions as we just talked about our
political institutions they have they
have brought in collectivism socialism
communism marxism whatever you want to
call it and they are destroying the
foundation of america starting with the
foundational documents and the history
of america and everything else this book
is really hey
give them some credit you don't you may
not like what they did but they've done
it we all know it every day another
crazy story comes out that we all have
to cover what can you do in the midst of
that to not just survive but thrive
there are things like hey maybe don't go
to college and get 150 000
into debt and then have some job that
you don't really like maybe learn a
trade there's all sorts of ways you know
take care of your digital assets so
you're not so reliant on big tech know
what you think and why you think it
these are sort of basic things in some
way but we need them now more than ever
because as i said earlier these guys are
not stopping and we all know it
great ideas great book check it out you
can
buy it everywhere wherever you buy books
it's called don't burn this country dave
rubin thank you very much for joining us
today thank you dave wishing you the
best with your book good to be with you
guys good to have you thanks
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell